[Música]
a questão social é uma questão
pedagógica
isso é uma coisa que já foi dita há pelo
menos cem anos e o que isso significa
significa que a questão social ela
depende de como nós acreditamos nas
idéias que não são ensinadas ela depende
também da maneira como nós nos sentimos
em relação a essas idéias que aprendemos
e principalmente a questão social tem
uma ligação direta com a forma que nós
agimos
a partir disso tudo é preciso ter
clareza de que nós não somos ensinados
nós não somos educados a observar e
temos que admitir que no fundo nós não
somos educados também para pensar ea
maioria dessas idéias que nos são
apresentadas nem através das quais nós
somos formados a nós precisamos admitir
que a maioria delas não são verdades
eu quero trazer um exemplo pra vocês têm
uma dessas idéias que nós repetimos com
muito orgulho tanto orgulho que quando
nós há repetimos nós batemos no peito e
muitas vezes vamos até adiante e batemos
na mesa que é quando nós dizemos eu vivo
do meu trabalho eu vivo do meu trabalho
mas se nós fizemos uma observação
simples na verdade né se nós observamos
no mundo real
o que nós vamos perceber
que a roupa que eu visto não fui eu que
costurei o alimento que eu como não fui
eu que plantei a casa onde eu moro onde
eu vivo
não fui eu que construir isso tudo é
fruto do trabalho alheio e tudo quase
tudo que eu faço eu faço para o outro
então eu não sei se depois de fazer uma
pequena observação como essa seria capaz
de nós conseguimos continuar afirmando
que nós vivemos do nosso trabalho
quero trazer também ainda um outro
exemplo que parte da observação para o
pensamento para reflexão sobre algumas
coisas que é o seguinte todos nós já
ouvimos dizer isso virou uma moda
comparar o corpo humano é uma máquina
todos nós já ouvimos dizer e acreditamos
que o coração é uma bomba que bombeia o
sangue bom
a própria ciência convencional
tradicional já admitiu já descobriu que
o sangue ele circula num estágio muito
inicial já do desenvolvimento do embrião
antes mesmo do coração ser formado o
sistema circulatório já funciona o
sangue já circula e num dado momento
começa a se formar num ponto ali uma
mancha e essa mancha vai ser condensado
e se transformando um nódulo e ali é
formado o coração
o sangue já circula antes do primeiro
batimento cardíaco
isso é fato científico comprovado
só que nós nunca ouvimos falar sobre
essas coisas porque eu tô trazendo isso
porque não é preciso pegar uma
informação como
essa na verdade buscar sempre por mais
informações
tem que pegar informações como essas e
começar a pensar sobre elas
então num exemplo como esse é preciso no
mínimo me perguntar é o coração que
bombeia o sangue ou é o sangue que
bombeia o coração eu posso transformar
essa pergunta uma pergunta mais
artística e me perguntar é a fé é o é a
forma que gera o movimento ou é um
movimento que já era a forma posso um
pouquinho mais além e me perguntar o que
impulsiona o que trazer isso para
reflexões pessoais e tem um time
conscientiza do o que me move o que é
que me impulsiona a final porque eu
estou trazendo esses exemplos né o que
nós percebemos que acontece aí o que
acontece há uma inversão uma inversão de
conceitos uma inversão de ideias e eu
estou trazendo isso como exemplo para
vocês entenderem que é isso que nós
fazemos numa iniciativa de csa e cse
significa como já dito comunidade que
sustenta a agricultura um movimento
mundial que já existe há décadas que
teve início aqui no brasil em 2011 no
bairro demétria em botucatu interior de
são paulo
o movimento que vem crescendo a cada ano
e o que nós fazemos dentro desse
movimento
nós invertemos a lógica do mercado num
csa já não é mais o agricultor não é
mais a agricultura que sustenta a
comunidade mas sim a comunidade que
sustenta a agricultura
nós partimos de sempre de fatos e
situações reais
né no caso nós fazemos um levantamento
do valor da produção dos custos da
produção e dividimos esses custos entre
um grupo de pessoas da sociedade civil
organizada
o dof steiner é por volta de 1919 no
livro chamado os pontos cerne da questão
social ele escreve o seguinte que um
produto ou os meios de produção ele só
deveriam custar algo enquanto eles estão
sendo produzidos que depois de pronto
esse produto ele deveria ser colocado à
disposição e serviço da sociedade
para sua construção isso pode parecer um
pouco utópico até meio maluco mas é isso
que nós realizamos dentro de uma
iniciativa de csa
nós calculamos esse custo de produção
dividimos esse valor entre um grupo de
pessoas dentro de um movimento como esse
a não existe compra e não existe venda
o que nós fazemos ali é realmente apoiar
a produção e isso se dá através de um
simples detalhe que é que essas
contribuições mensais elas são feitas no
início e não no final do mês
o que isso traz como diferença que nós
através de um pequeno detalhe como esse
assumimos o compromisso de carregar
junto com o agricultor as dificuldades e
os riscos da produção
isso é uma coisa muito interessante
porque nós dizemos dentro do csa que os
membros eles não são mais consumidores
eles passam a ser com agricultores
essa essa forma de lhe dar essa forma de
inverter algumas dessas
lógicas ela elimina a alguns alguns nós
que nós temos
ântero dessas relações de de troca
vamos falar assim né am entre entre as
pessoas ea agricultura
quando nós fazemos uma observação real
do que custa a produção
nós percebemos por exemplo que dentro da
elaboração de custos
existe uma grande mentira também
inventada pelo capitalismo que todos nós
acreditamos e muitos de nós até gostamos
que se chama lucro lucro é uma coisa
irreal um valor especulativo que não
existe em parte nenhuma da produção o
lucro pra mim eu cheguei à conclusão
ele é um dos fermentos do egoísmo e o
pai do acúmulo não precisamos realmente
começar a refletir sobre coisas desse
tipo
senão não vamos conseguir causar
mudanças nenhuma
e essas primeiras mudanças nós
precisamos causar dentro de nós o que
acontece dentro de um csa também é que
nós começamos a participar de um
processo de auto educação
nós estamos acostumados a sair à feira e
escolher o que nós queremos comer e
muitas vezes nós nem nos perguntamos se
época ou não daqueles alimentos e muitas
vezes nós encontramos esses alimentos lá
e não nos perguntamos de onde eles vêm e
que custo isso tudo teve de produção
para o meio ambiente e para o que eu tô
com o que eu estou colaborando
quando eu faça escolhas desse tipo no
csa nós não escolhemos o que nós vamos
receber nas sextas semanais
contribuímos mensalmente e em
contrapartida nós recebemos semanalmente
uma cesta de alimentos orgânicos
sazionais né então nós não escolhemos a
cada semana que você vai buscar a sua
cesta de csa é você tem ali uma grande
surpresa
um amigo dizia que um csa toda semana é
natal
toda semana você ganha um presente e é
um presente desafiador também porque
muitas vezes são coisas que você não
conhece
então você começa a se ver mexido no seu
campo na sua zona de conforto e tem que
agora pensar e se virar pra ver o que
você vai fazer com aquele alimento bom
educação no fundo sempre é alta educação
e educação sempre é educação da vontade
no caso da força de vontade e quando nós
observamos os reinos da natureza
nós vamos perceber que nos reinos da
natureza
as mudanças de transformações
elas acontecem ou pelo menos deveriam
acontecer o poderiam acontecer por si só
no reino humano no campo das relações
sociais no campo das questões sociais
não é assim no campo das questões
sociais as mudanças elas precisam ser
provocadas e nós vemos que nós estamos
numa época onde muitas dessas mudanças
começaram onde muitas pessoas
vimos grandes exemplos já né e se
tornaram a
estão participando dessa mudança
causando essas mudanças e eu acho que
realmente é chegado o tempo ea questão
que fica para nós hoje
na verdade é decidir cada um para si
se você quer participar dessa mudança ou
se você quer continuar vivendo da forma
que você está
e essa mudança dela não são coisas tão
[Música]
fantásticas e às vezes até tão
agradáveis ou tão felizes como nós
imaginamos gente precisa realmente
procurar dentro de nós onde a questão
esses pontos onde é que vivem essas
questões que nós nunca refletimos sobre
elas e seguimos automaticamente sem sem
sequer pensar no que isso tudo causa
aqui em lavras tem um csa nós fundamos o
primeiro set a 1
como eu disse em botucatu em 2011 e hoje
nós temos mais de 100 cs as iniciativas
de csa pelo brasil o brasil é um dos
países que desenvolveu em tempo mais
curto
a quantidade de iniciativas de csa isso
mostra um potencial muito grande desse
povo das pessoas da nossa capacidade de
produção da nossa capacidade criativa e
eu acho que
nós realmente realmente precisamos
a partir de hoje que tem muitos campos
que não precisa mexer a educação sem
dúvida é um deles mas a questão da
alimentação a questão agrícola a questão
do papel do agricultor na sociedade a
questão da valorização do trabalho
agrícola ela precisa realmente ser
repensada
não pelo governo apenas mas por todos
nós porque a profissão de agricultor
eu acho que nós podemos afirmar que é a
profissão mais importante que existe nós
podemos viver sem muitas coisas mas nós
não podemos viver sem alimentos
e quando falo de alimentos eu tô falando
de alimento de verdade nós são muito
visitadas
os contemplados por todo esse trabalho
que os agricultores realizam no mínimo
três vezes por dia quando sentamos para
nos alimentar
eu acho que não é mais possível que a
gente continue a esse sono essa
dormência em relação à situação agrícola
csa uma das possibilidades que nós temos
para mudar essa relação
e é esse contato direto que nós chamamos
na verdade de economia viva economia
solidária que vai criar uma relação
porque a gente chama de economia
solidária porque nós apoiamos essa
agricultor durante os 12 meses do ano
nós o apoiamos principalmente nos
momentos de crise
assim como nós não abandonamos um
familiar um grande amigo num momento de
crise é esse tipo de relação que a gente
precisa desenvolver não só com a
agricultura mas em todos os campos
na verdade porque essa visão capitalista
que nos torna cegamente egoístas
isso realmente não tem mais para onde
nos levar
eu espero que vocês todos queiram e
decidam tomar parte dessa mudança acha
[Aplausos]